here's another thing - hmm which is I
think a big thing go this is that I
haven't for the last two years three
years I've been to maybe two Amer can we
talk about that yeah we did on yours and
I so not only so as all this do I have
that I have I'm a dry drunk no your
reporter yeah yeah I don't I'm not
really working on my recovery at all and
I'm using I can see myself fall back
into so that's what this feels like to
me like like like what this mishegoss
you know I
shenanigans right you know what I mean
like you need to like get stuff straight
good cold turkey and gets going some
meetings and see what the hell's going
on like I feel like I'm looking at like
wave smoke aside from see I have so much
why it's it's not gonna be that much
sake with that big a deal whatever it is
you face down way more I mean what we're
doing by penis enlargement is that we're
going though willing to offer that
information yes he has these addictions
isn't this what do you call it when
someone is so clear and acknowledges
their issues and they have a lot of
these oh my god moments like when you
told him right now like that's a process
thing and he's like oh my god and he has
a lot of these every day and he
acknowledges all these things but
they're it's a hundred percent in action
zero percent actually working towards
any of those things that he talks about
in acknowledges every day okay hey look
if this is a trial the judge oh no
dodged some question yeah go ahead it's
good right she's great yeah she's right
what she's correct does she not okay
that's good
because because I don't that a
codependent would go I'm confused she's
like hey you complain but he goes to
thank or any meetings what the hell
what's the expected but here's the thing
though
could I just say something yeah okay
this is that every time I've gotten
sober maybe two times in my life right
and maybe I only know of two yeah I have
said when I was 17 years old I got sober
I relapsed after 12 years is that guy
still around like I the tattooed guy
from the guy that saved your life oh
yeah remember the cat around you still
wrong yeah dan is gone I know I said I
have his number to call okay
that's insane it should say I should
call you tomorrow
maybe commit to me but he loves us and
II do okay but here's the thing okay is
it that two times that I will start the
wheel they will start this thing and you
know what you two first of all you do
all the other ones on the thing right I
know I seem vulnerable right now I'm Stu
your [ __ ] captain [ __ ] you know I
got the cab you should know he was going
up in their eyes every second yeah I'm
telling you all right yes but the two
times that I have been sober is a I have
I get motivated when I'm in extreme pain
of course okay yes that's when I like it
so I if I feel like I'm gonna die yeah I
know or its life for you no life for gas
dude that's when I change my thing I
know you
Hinske yeah dr. Drew Pinsky so hey so
you've done that twice with with
alcoholism right right yep with this
with this this stuff the ease issues
you're talking about right now right yes
it affects you know men our relationship
but still it's still we're still
symbiotic we're still in this
relationship art Lee my fault because I
think I have a very high threshold for
[ __ ] and I do make it I think that
I'm you're taller right you see it an
tolerator eye because it's a
self-protective thing for mine I don't
like engage and fight a lot and I think
that especially with him I do make his
life like you know he says he has to be
in pain to change yeah yeah his life is
not painful with me it's I make things
fairly easy around the house does she
need to go to al-anon I mean I probably
do Allinol I think so but here's another
thing that I where our relationship has
gone to is dump this all in dr. juice so
good I know he loves it there is us a
parental thing that's kind of happening
where she tells me I just it feels like
my mom hmm
right thank clean that you know I eat
that yeah I'm not I'm not surprised
you're saying that and that's exactly
the kind of stuff I expect to see emerge
when you get all the [ __ ] out of the way
like the porn and everything else like
this kind of thing is then you could
then when it comes during the day and
you don't want to clean up you're gonna
go hey we got to talk about this instead
you go porn what I'll do is you know
like she'll go like I'll go hey can I
get Jersey because we'd get a lot of
post mates mm-hmm so today I woke up and
I'm like I'm hungry what do you want
well stop behaving like your mom's sign
comes out of the room in his underwear
and he goes you call me Oh mommy right
and she goes what do you want
so cheats talk to be like her I'm like
your mom right so I come on that's where
you're my god no one Jews I want to go
to eat I say I wouldn't go the easy way
she knows what that means
you could die you know and all that
stuff and I go I'll get the salad this
has gone fully into your mom's relation
abhi you're gonna be chasing him in a
field with your carve-outs up
he remembers every story look at that
Wow Wow I remember Dan Irwin he
remembered the car that's crazy
a lot of people I tell these stories
they don't remember maybe because
they're dumb comedians but comedians are
very that dumb so this there's a lot
here there's a lot but it's not it's
it's not super deep listen I know that
these issues are in play I'm not blinded
to hold my hair when I get real I want
to get forward I want to lock eyes with
okay you sir okay done so I know that
these issues they're already looking at
the table all right guys relax I'm fine
all right so what it is it's like when
you know you give someone a [ __ ] yeah
okay so anyway okay so the it you know
the issues are on the table I am you
know not blind to what's going on in my
personal life right but still with all
that in play I'm sad that you guys
aren't having sex every day [ __ ] I know
that I still that's ridiculous
I still there's no effect if she puts up
with that I know oh my god but still
dude I know not but still but let's
correct that it's important part of
relationship really important I know and
if I finally asked him I said look this
isn't does this I'm widel 30 some young
30 something year old girl and I told
him that's like I don't want to continue
to keep taking the initiative and trying
to fix everything about us so I told him
you find a therapist you take you take
this matter into your own hands and I've
asked you that and then the last time I
asked you because you find one and I was
like no I asked you nicely that I'm
leaving I'm gonna I just need one sign
from you that you're willing to was
calling Dan tomorrow I know but he's
gonna text me after he call